since we're being honest what about all
this [ __ ] about Charlie Sheen why is
everybody saying that I was [ __ ]
Charlie Sheen and then I had a disease
that is not true but you knew about this
story because I remember by Miller I
asked you about it you didn't have sex
with Charlie Sheen no I did not have
such a Charlie Sheen I know him yes he
was a really good friend of mine but but
but but but all the details before this
stuff but he's actually a good friend of
yours he was a he well like a good
friend he was an amazing friend to me
John time that we were in a part of each
other's lives okay I haven't spoken to
him in about three years but yeah he
saved me from an abusive relationship
from a person that one had gone out to
Hollywood and gotten themselves on drugs
I was behind the scenes I was being
abused I was dealing with all kinds of
crazy stuff and his friendship meant the
world to me
mm-hmm he gave me the ability to have
the freedom to express myself with my
art he was a backer to me he took
amazing care of me so yes that part is
true
him and I have never had sex and I don't
have any [ __ ] diseases people that is
one thing that was really hard to show
you a disease I never heard oh my god if
you googled us the situation with me and
Charlie after the tightest of it
happened right that was like boom boom
boom they took it and started IV gave a
statement they contacted me because
years ago someone threatened to release
the story before any of the tightest
that happen mm-hmm some girl taking a
picture of me over at Charlie's house
and gave it to the tabloids and said
they were gonna release this story about
me and there's a girl who's jealous
because he'd spoiled the [ __ ] out of me
I was having a hard time so the guy was
like super nice to me
and these girls that were actually
sleeping with him and there I saw
countless of them little [ __ ] or
jealous because he would be extra
generous to me super kind to me and you
never slept with him no I didn't give
any money because he's a good guy wasn't
even in just about money he was helping
me to get away from an abusive situation
and I was no longer happy being in the
adult industry and I didn't want to feel
trapped in that world anymore he was the
most amazing person so do you think he
was frustrated that he didn't get to
have sex with you
you know what honestly I feel like he
could have if you wanted to because I
respected him so much and he was so good
to me
that actually I was kind of pissed that
he wouldn't sleep with me because he was
sleeping with all these girls movie
stars and all this stuff and he's
Penthouse Pets or whatnot peanuts but
just like you know Center fold shirts
gorgeous women and I was like well why
are you always want me over here while
you always wanted to hang out with me
why are we sitting up there like when he
would tell me everything so I knew a lot
of them I just didn't know about what he
was going through but I knew whatever it
was was something dark because I would
always like God rewrote my poetry to him
and he would tell me some of his poetry
all the time like he's a really good
writer
is he a good poet yeah he's actually
really good but his stuff is scary what
was one of his poems uh one of them was
about that really caught my eye that
made sense to me much later on when
everything came out about him mm-hmm
something about the Grim Reaper and he
would read was like reading me this poem
and he didn't have to read it from
anything he just had it in his mind and
I remember him telling me that was just
like that's so sad like you have
everything a man could want in the
entire world and you know you had these
dark thoughts like I didn't know what
was going on with him now years later
when I found out what he was privately
going through he was going through
during that time that I was his friend
so I was a part of his life during one
of the darkest times for him and for me
as well and I believe in some kind of
way I was meant to be there for him
because I was kind of like a
psychiatrist how'd you guys meet uh one
of his girls invited me over and when
his girlfriends because they were a fan
of mine and they had all my sex toys and
they were using my sex toys and she was
like wouldn't that be cool we could give
me as about to come over and hang out
with us so they had me come over and as
like a you know an appearance to come
and see him and meet him and I get there
and these all these gorgeous girls
hanging out in there they're having sex
with my sex toys and I'm just kind of
like in shock I walk into this you know
house and I'm just like what the hell is
going on here but he was super friendly
super open super warm-hearted super just
cool really really cool like the coolest
person I've ever met in Hollywood it's
funny to mean that every girl that ever
walked in that house had to sign a
nondisclosure agreement he never made me
do that there made me feel out people he
never made me feel like I was a secret
or anything bad about me he was just the
coolest person and I if he's listening
to this or hears about the show I wanna
tell him thank you so much for what he
did
why do you suppose that was general you
were guessing some of the reasons that
he might have had her over and stuff
well of course he was you and you would
think that we were sleeping together but
that wasn't true that was not true that
would have been my gas at the time so he
definitely didn't he was protecting me
from that I asked him once like why
don't you sleep with me why don't you
sleep with everybody else doesn't thing
wrong What did he say a lot of respect I
was like okay but yeah sleeping with
someone doesn't mean you don't respect
them that's when you're going through
that they said there was rumors that he
didn't tell people I obviously don't
know the truth of that I don't know
either that's one things I don't know
that I know he was being blackmailed by
people because he told me a lot of stuff
yeah I heard there was million what were
they blackmailing him for I don't know I
don't know what the things were for just
oh they were different people that are
blackmailing him for 10 million dollars
and black men over time I'm sure added
out to be that much I think he said that
he was before he announced to the world
that he had HIV or whatever that he was
getting blackmailed by people who were
gonna expose that someone took a photo I
think of medicine I heard yeah I don't
know other things which have been
substantial I want to say him right who
cares why would I say that something in
the chamber I don't like to say rumors
like that cuz then you [ __ ] put that
on somebody but you can you can look up
my name in his name and they'll try to
snore have didn't say that I was
positive they tried to elude with the
kind of allegedly his girlfriend Mia's a
fellow or this that in the third but I
had never even my statement that I had
gay I had given to the public when they
contacted me was simply saying he was
one of the most incredible friends I've
ever had
I was sorry to hear that news about his
situation but I knew that if anybody
could handle dealing with this and a
major public way it'd be him because if
she doesn't give a [ __ ] a lot of times
he's like he's a strong person and they
took that and tried to say that I was
sleeping with him and I scared the
Kardashians in the Kylie girl because I
was dating Charlie Sheen and they
started spinning it and it just it just
privately however how did he know how
did he tell you he didn't tell me I
didn't know anything oh he never told
you I knew I didn't I knew a lot of
things about
but I didn't know that I just knew you
were suffering through something really
hard by the way he interacted with me
and things he would tell me but he'd
never told me that
have you ever have you